Andthen
[Music]
and
[Music
] our production of protein of vegetable origin
allows us to enter
some areas of human food that
not only vegetarian and that is not
vegan I would say that it gives a very
interesting part that we haven't yet  it is
developed that medical clinical food
so that they go to areas of people
who are sick, they have to be
twice as hard to take
products with a little bit of high
intensity from them.
sustainable But on the other hand They
also bring nutritional benefits to
people and microalgae which are
extremely important ingredients
because they are rich they want protein they want
bioactive compounds and therefore they are an
extremely important nutritional source
and can be applied in
various food matrices 1
[Laughter]
What's up
[Music]